hey guys welcome to a brand new video
today I'm going to be attempting to earn
a bond in the quickest enough time
possible and I'm just gonna be using my
main account I haven't done this before
so imagine you've been away all weekend
someone's logged into your account
hacked all your stuff and you come back
and you only have five hours of
membership left what do you do I'm going
to see what it's going to be a quickest
way just to get a bond I don't have
extremely high stats but here are my
stats I have 70 all combat 84 magic and
if you range and reasonably high but not
like not in game by any means of all the
rest of my stats and I won't be using
most of these but the first thing I'm
gonna be doing is of course picking up
some items just to get it starting the
mounts I literally have nothing no items
nothing on me and anything my bank is
off limits and you know see where I can
go from here ok so the first method I
want to do is actually going to be
buying potions and food from the
Warriors guild which has been one of my
more favorite methods actually I do it
pretty consistently magic need a little
bit of quick money so what I need first
off is just a tiny bit of cash and a
teleport to the Warriors guild
now the quickest way is just going to be
to use a game's necklace so I'm going to
pick up some ashes off the ground just
to get this started here and you don't
really need a lot of cash to start
buying from the shop actually only
probably 3 or 4 K will be enough that's
what we're actually to do is just chop
some oak logs ok so we still the mana
for two and eight coins will buy an axe
I'll buy a iron axe because you don't
really need a good one and buy that for
20 coins and let's get to chopping and
we'll just need a little bit of money
ok so we've been chopping oak logs for
just about 10 minutes now what we ended
up buying was one game's necklace and we
upgraded to in edimax
or sorry miss relax which will go off
and sell now and that's pretty much all
we need is this the quickest way to get
a little bit of money probably not but
it was
people and it's right the grant exchange
which is kind of a little bit
time-saving this will go ahead and drop
those in here pop those down and we'll
sell off the iron axe as well as the
mist relax okay so let collect and we
have a 2.8 K which is not a lot is the
worth buying a Rock teleport yeah I
guess I want to come back here and sell
off our stuff so buy one of those and
that leaves us with about 2k that's all
will probably need for NAB we'll have to
run back here and sell off some of the
stuff I think this will end up being
quicker so go ahead and teleport to
burthorpe
which is where the Warriors guild is now
get in here you will need 65 attacking
strength or 99 in one of them which is
less likely but all you do is open the
door here and head over to these shops
it's right beside a bank which is pretty
convenient and it will just deposit that
but remember that we ended up buying one
of the tailboard so what we have to do
is just talk to Lydia verbally but we
might buy some stuff from Lily as well
and perfect look at that there's tons of
these in the shop right now
and just buy out the stock so that is in
hot world and we'll go here normally
there's some iron men doing this or
other people doing this method but [__]
you
yep see no one buys out the stews so go
do this till our inventory is empty or
gold is run out and then we'll go sell
it and then repeat this for about an
hour okay so we pretty much did that so
I guess ten minutes or so and we just
need to sell these pieces there we go as
well click that and we're up to 33 K
that is enough so we'll be able to do
that for at least an hour for sure now
and Barok teleport pretty sure this guy
in orange is trying to scam me and yeah
let's go back cool okay so we'll pretend
that didn't happen
so yeah we'll do 33 K pre kind of money
I'll check in but I think this should
last us for quite a while and it will be
back once have spent all the money okay
so we stuck this out for about an hour
and we ends up getting well we had a bit
more than this but we ended up just
sawing off as we didn't have to buy
more stuff from the shop but we ended up
getting 412 plain pizzas and they still
don't so I'm Stu's 190 of those or I'm
sorry 305 of those they're selling 490
and we got a lot of potatoes with cheese
now which is pretty nice and we always
have to bump these down a little bit
more and there we go and on the way we
also just bought our battle stuffs for
the day why not and sell those off
so if collect all our money we're at 637
K and we're just over an hour but
getting 600 M K in the first hour is
pretty good comparative to some of the
other ways you can do it so something I
haven't actually done in quite a while
is kill dragons and an easy one to do
with some kind of welfare gear is
killing Green Dragons in the wilderness
so going to go risk it coming to the
Lord Ernest and kill dragons I think
it's six hundred to seven thirteen hour
maybe my range is 83 now as I probably
will make a bit of a difference but
we're just going to be rockin a room
crossbow and some broad bolt and black
tea ID and that we will deposit my new
symbols have to remember we have 568 kms
and anything we could buy gets good by
an archers helm why not just sell it
back after and we'll bring some food
with us as well and we should have a
lose bean bag in our bank already and
we'll do down to 50 lobsters why not
so weird about 517 K we'll meet you in
the wilderness and I'll get started okay
we're in the wilderness we're just
finishing up a our first inventory of
Green Dragons and we just stole this
person spot because has a cannon here
for some reason and yeah so we just got
one more dragging the kill as everyone
tailboard up here this inventory took so
far 13 minutes it's not too bad we
filled up the looting bag already and
this should be our last kill and we'll
get out of here I don't we'll go ahead
and price check how much is actually
worth definitely clicker with 82 range
over-60s when I think I'll actually did
this last been quite a while and our
last dragon kill is going to be the same
thing okay so when inventory was worth
one
100 K which isn't too bad we can do I
think five of these in an hour so we'll
go ahead and finish up the hour
hopefully there is no incident and
you'll be back then okay guys so we just
finished up with the hour of killing
green dragons and it wasn't as good as I
remember I probably could optimize it a
little better and I was comforting to
pick up some of the drops but anyway
let's go ahead collect and that brings
us up to just past a mil plus we have a
little bit gear on it's maybe around one
point one mil maybe one point two so now
what I'm thinking of doing is actually
just doing some barrows runs super
simple all I'm going to need is a
trident for that i want to put some
charges in it but we'll buy the empty
trident give can't afford the full one
really so will you see regular tridents
of the toxic riding that's way cheaper
and i don't really know if even that
little much less effective thank you bye
there we go
and we already have our pretty much our
setup we're just going to be wearing
black d ID all this crap whatever and
all we're going to need is you tried it
charged to try it into ambles buy some
supplies okay guys so this is what I'm
investing in I get my range so that for
barrows and I'm just going to equip the
occult necklace a trident with some
charges as well as a dragon scimitar for
getting the kill count in the tunnel I'm
not sure if the room crossbows gonna be
better or not want to see and we'll have
to put charges in trident
there we go 500 charges in trident and
we have 144 calif dover and some prayer
potions and yes let's go start and do
some barrows okay guys we just finished
up ten bears chest and in this gear it's
taking a little bit longer than like but
we still have about 600 k from that now
i don't know if we're going to make it
at this rate we're getting pretty close
only an hour and a half left and well
we'll solve all these runes and it will
go to a farm run but i think i might
just continue doing some barrows and
hope i get an item it's probably my best
chance otherwise we will have failed my
little tiny goal here give me
in five hours but what to see so will
sell off all this junk here and it
collects that brings up to 640 K as well
go ahead and buy clothes we can
redundant I'll put more charges into the
Trident I hopefully can do a little more
than 10 and that will go do farm run as
well and maybe just maybe we'll make it
in time
okay there we go we bought 60 lakh seeds
we did put some in earlier and we should
go be able to harvest them now and we
bought some more charges for the Trident
which will go ahead and promptly toss in
there
and we'll go ahead and complete the
farmer now I think okay so we just
finished up our top flax run and if we
did do one earlier as well so we'll go
just sell out except with a notepad and
I'm going to lose the notepad and it
will set off 170 K pretty good for just
two runs okay guys so unfortunately we
got a little bit unlucky and I didn't
end up getting any items from I guess
one T barrows chest ah which is that I
thought super unlucky but if I got in an
item I think I would have had this in
five hours pretty easily but as it is I
got pretty lucky on the runes actually
to go ahead and price check this
actually got over seven RK in runes so I
guess is not all terrible but yeah I'm a
little disappointed but either way let's
go to sell everything off and see what
red and we'll just finish it up with
just something quick okay so it brought
us up to just over two mil and yeah one
item when they've been perfect as it
stands we need about another 500 K so
I'm just going to go ahead and maybe
continue on with the first method
because it's so simple
okay guys so what ended up doing was
setting the timer for another hour and I
ended up just going ahead and going back
to the Warriors guild and buying up some
items and we're just finishing up the
last farm where and that managed to do
three and the well now is closer to six
hours which is pretty on top of it
relatively exists every hour and 20
minutes so you can do run roughly that's
a pretty good there now the one issue I
had here was obviously I didn't get any
drops and I'm not sure if my luck had
been
average I would have probably made it
within the five hours unfortunately it
wasn't and that's kind of why I was
initially hesitant to go with a more RNG
based money making method because you
can invest a lot of time into something
and just not get anything back or get
extremely lucky and it's still a little
bit biased and not really accurate but I
decided to go to barrows because the
money was pretty consistent even without
the drops and unfortunately I didn't
quite get it but we'll have this
completed and I think six hours which
isn't too bad but I'm sure I could do
better okay so pretty solid run actually
48 crop so we have two mill cash a bunch
of random food miscellaneous items from
the Border's guild as well as close to
fifty toadflax which is worth because
over under kay it's a little bit more
okay so back at the grand exchange we're
going to sell everything off now it
looks like the price of a bond is about
2.6 million ease is worth just about
under kay nice and sell off all the
stews the plain pizzas and of course the
potato with Jesus okay after collecting
we get 26.1 the 4k oh my god someone
built a swastika as a burnt monkfish
come on guys
okay we're in try find it for 2614 and I
think that should be enough perfect
there we go
bond achieved and we got the bond for
2.5 mill and some change so anyway guys
it took about six hours didn't beat my
last time unfortunately even though I
had access to my entire account and
because I kind of failed a bit of this
one I'm going to be giving away the bond
so all you guys got to do to enter is
just leave a comment on the video and a
like if you are so inclined
but honestly and there's you know as
well as I do that there's no way for me
to check who liked the video so anyway
guys hope you enjoyed and I will see you
in the next one
[Music]